over the weekend Russia's most popular
iron man hit the ice glad Amir Putin
showed off his hockey skills during an
exhibition match and Sochi with former
NHL players the 62-year old president
scored an impressive eight goals in his
team's 18 26 victory during his 15 years
in power Putin has captivated quite the
image are cultivated quite the image of
toughness with a variety of physical
stunts he's been seen there is fishing
shirtless riding a horse through the
mountains flying on a motorized hang
glider he's also a black belt in judo
who knows how to shoot a bow and arrow
Shh maybe he has pictures of people that
he puts up there to do our tree practice
but you know one of the interesting
things about the the hockey event that
he took place it's the same weekend that
yesterday the Canadians beat the
Russians to take the title of the world
hockey a federal like there he is well
there he is you don't necessarily want
to be the goalie defending against
Vladimir Putin I wonder if you don't let
the goals in you know what happens to
you I that's right well and this is why
you know almost entirely the West
despises him but he is immensely popular
yes very high approval ratings right and
and part of this might be the fact that
he is such an unusual leader right some
of his antics as well he hopes i would
think to endear him to some of his
critics like to see him and President
Obama at a basketball shootout has it oh
there you go I think I'll go work on
that right now I think I was better
Obama on that one yeah I think so